[Music]
this episode is brought to you by fresh
books longtime listeners of this podcast
know that I've been talking about fresh
books for years
it's the all-in-one invoicing payments
and accounting solution it came about
because I was doing a revision of the
4-hour workweek for 2009 looking at new
software solutions that could help
people help my readers and first books
came up over and over and over again
many entrepreneurs as well as
contractors and freelancers I work with
all the time use fresh books more and
more every day why is that well most
people especially entrepreneurs business
builders hate wasting time doing things
in efficiently painful invoicing with
different cobble together solutions
including Word or Excel can fall into
that category if you want to avoid that
pain what can you do give fresh books a
try fresh books is accounting software
that makes invoicing and other
bookkeeping tasks so easy you can save
up to 200 hours per year that's a lot of
hours here's how it makes running your
business easier you can automate bank
reconciliation in just a few clicks you
can give your accountant access to the
information they need to do your taxes
this is a huge one I've realized how
important this is and how much it makes
life easier when you get this done with
many things you can't accept credit card
and ACH payments right on invoices to
get paid two times faster and of course
you can create customized and send
branded and professional-looking
invoices in about 30 seconds with plans
starting at just 15 dollars per month
fresh books is designed to grow with
your business and right now fresh books
is offering my listeners that's you guys
a free 30-day trial with no credit card
required simply go to fresh ebooks.com
slash tim and enter tim ferriss in the
how did you hear about us section that's
Ferriss with two hours into us is of
course check it out go to fresh books
calm slash tim and start your free
30-day trial today first books calm
slash tim
this episode is brought to you by brave
the next generation web browser
I love brave and if you haven't heard
about it here is the skinny brave was
built by team of privacy focused
performance oriented pioneers of the web
and I do mean pioneers brave was
co-founded by Brendan Eich the I CH in
Brian Bondi Brendan was previously the
co-founder of Mozilla Firefox and the
creator of JavaScript brave now has more
than 10 million monthly active users and
I'm one of them why why would I use
brave because brave gives you unmatched
speed security and privacy and when I
say unmatched I mean the difference is
hard to believe and here's why every
time you download a web page when you go
to any web page you are not just
downloading the text and images you are
also downloading web junk this includes
trackers and scripts that run in the
background slowing your downloads and
wasting your time by an average of 5
seconds per page while also draining
your battery faster and costing you
extra in data charges there is a way to
have the best experience web can offer
and that is by using brave brave is up
to 6 times faster than other browsers
and it's truly incredible how much
faster everything is I have used brave
for instance to get on airplane Wi-Fi
when other browsers crash I have used it
to watch YouTube videos when it's just
suspended in loading forever on other
browsers it's not subtle at all there's
a huge difference other browsers act
like a vacuum cleaner for your data so
this is on the security privacy side you
were being profiled and tracked across
the web so what you might ask well data
collected about you can be used to
manipulate both your decisions and
countrywide decisions like elections and
if you want more on that listen to my
episode with Tristan Harris brave is a
way to protect yourself and remove the
surveillance economy brave also includes
options which I use quite often such as
private window with tor for those
seeking advanced privacy and safety this
browser feels intuitive it's super easy
to use you can import your bookmarks
with one click and all your favorite
Chrome extensions are also available
with brave and it doesn't have to be
either/or you can use multiple browsers
for different things
now listeners of this show the Tim
Ferriss show can easily upgrade their
browser for free and all you have to do
is go to brave comm forward slash Tim
that's brave comm Ford / Tim I use brave
all the time and I strongly suggest that
you at least test it out so go to brave
comm forward slash Tim and give it a
shot hello hello hello Nelly
this is Tim Ferriss I figured out mix up
the intro welcome to another episode of
the Tim Ferriss show where it is my job
each episode typically to sit down with
world-class performers of all different
types from all different industries from
all different fields to tease out the
habits routines favorite books
influences and so on that you can in
some fashion emulate or test and apply
in your own life this time around in
this episode we have a slightly
different format which I'm super excited
about I will not be the one doing the
deconstructing instead we have my good
friend Peter attea taking my place now
Peter Tia for those who don't know is
the common ingredient in two of the most
popular episodes on my podcast of the
last say hundred episodes specifically
those are episode number 352 dr. Peter
Atia vs. Tim Ferriss and episode number
398 Peter Tia MD fasting metformin
athletic performance and more if you
want to try one of those out after you
hear Peter do his thing here I would
suggest going to number 352 where we
talk about mental and emotional health
and different tools that can apply
they're coming back to this episode
though in this episode we have Peter
interviewing Sam's l ze ll a legendary
deal maker and investor and as of the
time of this recording Sam's net worth
stands at around five point two four
billion dollars as many listeners know
and many probably don't know dr. Peter
Chia on Twitter and Instagram
@ PT attea atti a md is a former ultra
endurance athlete so he's done swimming
races of 25 miles
et cetera a compulsive self experimenter
so we get along well and one of the most
fascinating human beings
I know he is also one of my go-to
doctors for anything related to
performance end longevity because
blending the two is quite a
sophisticated and subtle business Peter
also hosts the drive a weekly ultra deep
dive podcast focusing on maximizing
health longevity critical thinking and a
few other things he really gets into the
weeds with specialists on his show
topics include fasting ketosis
Alzheimer's disease cancer mental health
and much more you can subscribe to the
drive on Apple podcast Spotify or
wherever you listen to podcast and you
can find links to all of this in the
show notes for this episode at tim dot
blog forward slash podcast and just
search attea atti a i'll let Peter take
from here to give Sam's full bio and
introduce the episode this is one not to
miss I really enjoyed it and hope you do
as well thanks for listening
my guest in this interview is Samuel
Zell Sam is the chairman of equity group
investments he's also the chairman of
five companies listed on the New York
Stock Exchange he's a legendary
entrepreneur and investor who's active
across a broad range of industries
including energy manufacturing logistics
health care communications and of course
real estate Sam was recognized by Forbes
as one of the hundred greatest living
business minds in 2017 and he holds a
place on New York Stock Exchange's wall
of innovators for his role in building
the one trillion dollar REIT industry
he's the author of an amazing book am I
being too subtle which after I read the
book is the reason that I wanted to
interview him through this conversation
we cover a lot we start with arguably
the most important and transformative
aspect of Sam's life which is his
parents escape from Poland on the last
train out in World War two and how this
played an enormous role in his
upbringing talk about his early
businesses and in the lessons that he
learned along the way in particular how
he used these lessons to assess risk we
talked about his ability to assimilate
large volumes of information and how
that allowed him to basically play an
amazing role inside his business in
predicting the market crashes of
ninety-one in 2008 with respect
real estate talk about the incredible
loyalty within his organizations I won't
elaborate much more on this other than
to say it's by most standards quite
unique and I was surprised as I got to
know Sam just how much the people that
surround him share incredible loyalty to
him in fact after we recorded the
podcast we went out for dinner and
eventually found our way back to his
place and his driver gave me a ride back
home and I couldn't resist the
opportunity to just sort of pick his
brain and talk a little bit about that
and I was kind of blown away by the way
in which he talked about Sam and I
really got the impression this was not
something he was saying just because he
felt he needed to say that we talked
about how Sam takes in and processes so
much information and how this sort of
insatiable curiosity has really been the
cornerstone of his success we end with
Sam's thoughts on the current state of
the economy which is something I just
couldn't resist the opportunity to pick
his brain about this is one of the most
in-depth interviews Sam has given and
it's a real privilege and honor to have
been the one sitting across from him so
without further delay please enjoy my
conversation with Sam Zell
Sam thanks so much for making time today
and thanks for coming over my pleasure
there's so much I want to talk about but
I can't resist sort of starting at the
beginning which is the story before you
even came along before you were born
you've written very eloquently about
this in your book and it's clear that
it's shaped more of you than probably
most people would realize if they just
met you or even saw all of your
accolades tell me a little bit about
your parents and how they wound up
coming to the United States my parents
lived on a German Polish border in the
thirties and my father was a grain
merchant and a Jewish community in
Poland at that time was very very
limited and had very little exposure to
the outside world but my father because
he was in the grain business was dealing
with businessmen all over Europe and so
he had a much better understanding of
how the world had changed and the risk
that was occurring to the Jewish people
events like Kristallnacht that were
never reported in Poland he knew about
and he became alarmed that what was
happening and began planning to leave
Poland and go to the United States he
saved up money one of the stories that
owned the book is the story of him
basically getting money out of Poland
and getting it to Israel or to Palestine
at the time and so he in effect you went
on vacation to Egypt in Israel or
Palestine and basically there was the
Jewish organization that allowed Polish
Jews to get money out of Poland and so
one day a guy showed up at my mother's
house who had in effect my father had
told her look if some guy shows up he
can prove to you that I know him give
him all the money that's in the armoire
upstairs I think and in between my
mother who could received a letter from
my father and it was a typical rosy
letter or having a great time everything
is terrific
and when she opened up the letter she
found a ripped piece of paper inside the
envelope and then a week later a guy
shows up at her door with the other half
of the ripped piece of paper and that
proves to her who he is and she gave him
all the money and 48 hours later the
money was on deposit at Barclays Bank in
Tel Aviv and that money eventually
became the currency that they used when
they were escaping from Poland so it's
now 1939 it's August 23rd 1939 and the
world is stunned by the announcement of
the molotov-ribbentrop treaty which was
a treaty executed between Germany and
Russia and basically Stalin and Hitler
had made a deal and my father looked at
that treaty and said this is basically
an agreement to split up Poland and so
my father got off his on a train turned
around went home got my mother and said
we have to leave and he moved my mother
and my older sister who was like to a
couple hundred kilometers from their
town went back and tried to convince
other members of the family to come with
him without exception they all turned
him down he was like 34 years old I
think they all thought he was typical
over-enthusiastic young man didn't
understand didn't remember that in when
World War one happened the Germans
invaded Western Poland and the locals
found that to be terrific
they were much happier under the Germans
than they were under the poles the
Germans were educated the Germans were
cultured music art they thought it was
fabulous and they all said this is an
alarmist young man he didn't understand
as soon as the Germans come back it's
going to be terrific again and my father
instead knew about Kristallnacht knew
about all of the anti-jewish activity
in Germany and he couldn't convince
anybody to go with him and so finally at
4:30 in the afternoon of August 31st
1939 he got into train and started going
east and at 6:00 a.m. the Luftwaffe
bombed the rail yards and that was the
beginning of both the Germans and the
Russians invading Poland from either
side he then continued and just all he
wanted to do was keep going east
keep going away from Germany and their
times my mother told stories about her
pleading with him to stop ok we're far
enough away from the border everything
is going to be fine
instead all he said was we got to keep
going and they went by every conceivable
form of transportation from bus to train
to wagon cart whatever and whichever
methodology they could he kept going
east and along the way there were other
refugees just like them all move east
and eventually they got to Vilnius which
was the capital of Lithuania and that's
where the Russian army was and that's
where they paused they spent a few
months in Vilnius trying to get to
justed and at that time there were a lot
of other refugees in Vilnius and so
there was a community and they shared
information they were all confronted
with the same challenge which was how do
we get out of here
and most important how do we get visas
to get out of here while they were in
Vilnius the Dutch ambassador who come
out of Poland was on his way back to the
Netherlands but couldn't go west
so when East is stopped in Vilnius and
he gave out visas to Kersal curso is an
island in the Caribbean off the coast of
Venezuela and it was a Dutch
protectorate and they had historically
had an open visa policy to anybody
because they were trying to populate
curso particularly with Europeans and so
all of these refugees got the
Jesus to curse oh but the problem still
became how do you get from Vilnius to
Curacao and obviously the only way you
could go was East and obviously the
answer became the Japanese and they
found a consulate in covenants which is
the second largest city in Lithuania and
they told him her story and he took pity
on them and they literally created
something I called a transit visa now
there is no such thing as a transit visa
but they created it and they found a
wooden artisan who made a woodcut and
they created these visas and simply Suga
Hara who was the Consul ended up signing
almost 2000 of these and in the meantime
he sent a notice to Tokyo and asked
permission to grant the visas and they
came back and said no and then he sent
them a second question and while he was
waiting for them to respond is when he
filled out all the visas and when the
response came back they basically took
him and relocated him but the people had
these visas at the same time the Russian
government was desperate for hard
currency and so they decided that as
only Russian entrepreneurs that they had
a train and that they could sell in
effect train passes from Vilnius
overnight to Moscow and then 11 days and
11 nights on the trans-siberian Express
- a lot of us thought well you could
take a boat to Japan can my parents for
two hundred and thirty nine dollars per
person bought transit on that train
when overnight to Moscow spent the night
in Moscow as she went to the bolshevik
ballet and then the next morning got on
the train and spent the next 11 days and
11 nights on the train with their
two-year-old daughter going to the lot
of the stuff
and then eventually ported a boat and
ended up in Japan and then spent 6
months in Japan trying to get their visa
to the United States which they finally
got in may of 1941 and they arrived in
the United States May 18 1941 at 6:00
a.m. in Seattle interestingly enough as
only the life of an immigrant could
reflect they arrived at 6 a.m. in the
morning and 6 p.m. they took their first
English class because they were going to
become Americans and this was the most
important thing in their life so this
was kind of the background and I was
born September 28th so literally I was
born 1908 after they came to this
country and typical of my mother was
late with me and so the day I was born
she went to Marshall Fields which was
the major department store in Chicago
and started walking up and down the
stairs hoping that this would
precipitate the baby and eventually that
night at 10 o'clock the process started
and so they cut rest went downstairs got
on a streetcar and rode the streetcar to
the point where they had to get off and
change to go to the hospital but the
other streetcar didn't come and it was
11 o'clock at night so they walked the
last six blocks and then I was born very
shortly thereafter but when you come
from that kind of a life and you hear
the stories all over again for all of
your young period of time it gives you a
very different perspective on life the
idea of somebody literally picking up
and leaving where they were it's just
extraordinary how anybody could have the
self confidence I mean he didn't know
where he was going he had a wife and a
baby daughter and all he was doing was
going away from the threat so it made me
very aware of how lucky I was
he must have told me a hundred times how
lucky I was that I was born in the
United States how the streets of the
United States were paved with gold not
monetary gold but freedom and that was
really what it all meant and he over and
over again lectured me on how important
it was to understand how unique an
experience it was to live in a country
where you really had the freedom to make
decisions you had the freedom to work
harder or work less for change
professions or do whatever it is you
wanted to do as long as you didn't
disturb your neighbor so this was an
extraordinary background for everything
that eventually happened to me and
without question very much influenced
how I made decisions going forward
because more than anything else what had
told me was that anything was possible
you didn't start with a set of
limitations you started with the entire
spectrum was available and it was how
good you are how committed you were how
hard you were willing to work that
really was the limiting factors not the
society did your father ever articulate
to you in explicit or implicit terms his
decision-making process around because
when I hear that story Sam I think of a
huge asymmetry of risk so if you go back
to the moment the committed step which
is when your father had to decide to
leave or not to leave now he couldn't
have known that the train track was
going to be bombed in 12 hours and this
if I recall this was the last train out
of Poland this I mean you didn't leave
any margin there there's a very
asymmetric risk issue which is to be
wrong to leave unnecessarily has a
downside but to stay in correctly has
another downside obviously the latter
has a much bigger downside in other
words it's very asymmetric risk so from
a risk perspective your father made the
right decision not just because his
turned out to make it right but simply
on the basis of first principles your
whole life which we'll talk about as we
continue this discussion is so based on
understanding risk does that lesson
stand out to you in terms of teaching
that element of risk did your father
ever articulate it that way I don't
think he ever articulated it that way
cuz I don't think he ever thought about
it as risk and reward I think he thought
about it as survival I think he thought
about it and said what am i giving up
when we looked at the society that he
was leaving and particularly at his age
I think he really thought that he was
making a major decision for creating
optionality and freedom for his future
and I think that he had heard enough
of what was going on in Germany in
Austria at the time that I don't think
he had any doubt of how big the risk was
how critical it was to exit and yet he
was unable to convince everybody else
but everybody else were settled they had
their professions they were living in
this relatively small City and most
important had very little exposure to
the outside world I mean we live in a
day of 24/7 sound from the cable TV
stations and we live in a world where
there's newspapers every day that come
from all over the world and we can't
really relate to the idea of a society
where information was literally limited
and the further you got from the point
you were standing the less dependable
the information was so he was
functioning with a lot of information
that his siblings and his friends didn't
have no different than when we talked
about being a risk taker what I talk
about often is how critically important
it is to be as knowledgeable as possible
that all my life I've basically focused
on reading and digesting information
because the
well-educated up-to-date you are the
better you are to be able to assess
judgment and assess risk when we had
dinner a while back you told me a
footnote to the story you just told
which is years later I don't remember
how old you were he may have been five
six seven eight you came out of your
bedroom one night and your parents and
maybe some other friends I think were
huddled around a small movie projector
and they were watching something tell us
that story I think I was maybe six years
old and we live in Chicago and we lived
in what's commonly referred to as a
railroad apartment which is you had a
living room at the one end and the
kitchen at the other end and then it was
long row of bedrooms in bath and my
bedroom was at the far back next to the
kitchen and my parents had a group of
immigrants that had their own little
organization called the Harmony Circle
Club and once a month they would get
together in one the other one's living
room and talk about information
particularly information about Poland
and when they were all were refugees
from Poland and all Jewish and all
trying to get information I don't know
why I got up that night but I got up
that night and I snuck into the right
near the where the living room was and
they were watching an 8 millimeter movie
and I remember looking at the movie and
as I'm sitting here talking I can tell
you that I can represent the images that
I saw in the images were of trucks and
dump trucks and on the back of a dump
trucks in the bins were bodies and bones
and heads and in somehow whether they
had all been dumped in the back of these
trucks and then I learned for the first
time that this was all about the
Holocaust and these were smuggled out
movies that were made of what was going
on in these camps in Poland right before
the end of the war
and I sat there I mean at first I
couldn't conceive of what I was watching
and then when I talked to them about it
afterwards I never told them that I
snuck out to watch but we we talked
about things over the dinner table etc
I'm I began to understand that these
concentration camps literally were
created to wipe out a population and as
efficiently as possible kill them and
then put them in dump trucks and find
someplace where they could be dumped in
lime tossed on the bodies and buried
accordingly so it was an incredible
thing for a six-year-old to watch and
most important of all what I felt about
it was that but for the grace of God and
could have been should have been my
parents and in fact most of their
siblings ended up murdered in these
concentration camps when you think about
sort of your teenage years you have a
really unique set of personality traits
am one of them is you pretty much do
what you think is right whether it's
popular or not was that trait evident
when you were growing up was that trait
evident for example during adolescence
when most of us succumb to the need to
sort of be approved by others and do
what others think is the right thing to
do well I certainly was no different
than any other teenager but the fact
that I wasn't any different didn't
really change the fact that I was very
different and lived in a house where the
closeness to which they came to being
exterminated was very much aware for
everybody all the time
I grew up in a house where my parents
took the position man whatever I was
doing I was lucky I was doing it and I
had to do more of it I study harder and
I had to excel and other parents didn't
have these kinds of influence on their
children so it became obvious to me in a
relatively young age that I was
different and that as much as I wanted
to be accepted and as much as I wanted
to be like everybody else I also
recognized
that I wasn't and that I couldn't and
that at first it was very frustrating
and very much of a challenge and I
didn't really know what to do with it
and then eventually I just came to the
realization that I had to be my own
thing and I had to be who I was and that
other people had different ideas and
different objectives and that was fine
but I couldn't accept what everybody
else was thinking about I also grew up
in a world where the rest of the kids
that I grew up with they were kids but I
grew up in an environment where they
didn't really give me much of a chance
to be a kid in in fact whether it was a
six-year-old watching Holocaust movies
are all right listening to my father
telling me you went to a basketball game
last week why do you have to go again
and why are you so focused and having
fun you've got to be studying you got to
be getting better and you got to be able
to take on what's going on well needless
to say I didn't listen to everything he
had to say but living in that kind of
environment was very very different than
what my peers were doing so after
college how did you decide on law school
what other things did you think about
what did you have any sense of what you
wanted oh that was a very easy decision
my father's view was very simple you got
to have a profession no matter what you
got to have something that you can quote
a hanger shingle out on and law school
seemed like a very logical thing for me
to do academically I was very difficult
to achieve and so I went to law school
not because I wanted to practice law I
went to law school so I had a degree and
that if I didn't work out whatever it is
I was doing I would be able to in effect
still practice law and make a living and
that's what he more than anything
stressed I had to do so your first stint
in the law firm was a pretty short one
yeah well actually the better part of
the story is that I had 44 interviews 44
talked about rejection and I got
rejected by 43 and I sent all the
letters and I made all the appointments
and followed up on it
and what I didn't understand was that
and it was actually made very clear to
me when toward the end of this process I
had an interview with a big fancy firm
and I got through the first interview I
was very excited because I had been used
to people rejecting me and then I had a
second interview at the firm and went
really well and they set up a meeting
for me with the senior partner whose
name was on the door and I remember
going in to see him I walked into his
office and it was a typical wood-paneled
lawyer's office with books all over the
place and he was on the phone and he
just ikkyu lated with his hand and said
sit down and I sat down and he finished
the phone call then he got up and he
closed the drawer to his office and he
said tell me about your deals and I
looked at him and I said tell you about
my deals I want a job he said we would
never hire you you wouldn't last more
than three months I said what are you
talking about I said I want to be a
lawyer I went what about Perry Mason and
he laughed and he said you don't
understand and of course the truth was I
didn't understand and so I basically
asked him about it and he said do you
understand you put on your resume all
the things that you did while you were
in law school and while you were an
undergraduate and you built a real
estate business
you managed hundreds of apartments you
bought buildings you refinanced
buildings you wrote a manual on property
management and you're literally just
graduating from law school how would
anybody like you want to sit there and
draft contracts all day and I just
looked at him and I sweat and understand
he said the reason you've been rejected
like this it's because everybody looks
even and says this is a guy who's gonna
do something else and why would we want
to train him if he's gonna be gone very
shortly and never forget that interview
and ultimately did get one job actually
with a firm that was kind of half
entrepreneur half law firm
I've got there the first day and had
this tiny office so it was like 6x6 they
gave me a contract to do between a linen
supply company and a dormitory of
Northern Illinois University and some
client or the firm was built the
dormitory and they were entering into a
contract with a company that provided
Linens
they wanted me to write the contract
well for anybody who's been to law
school they know that the day you get
out of law school you don't know
anything about being a lawyer you may
know a lot about theoretical conflicts
of interest and broad concepts of the
law but how to draft a contract not a
chance particularly if you went to a
good law school where in effect they
looked down on any quote/unquote lawyer
vocational training and so I went and I
asked the guy who was sitting in the
next office and he gave me some forum
books and said here this gives you a
base and so I started working on the
farm books and it was terrible so I
submitted the first draft after a couple
of days and it came back and it looked
like the senior partner who had reviewed
it had slit his wrists because he used
red pen on it and the whole thing was
full of read this and read that and I'm
looking and saying I just went to three
years of law school and this is what
ends up and so I then redid it again and
finally submitted it to him and before
he responded to me I went into his
office on Friday morning and I said
could I speak to you for a second he
said sure and as only a 24 year old
would have fought I looked at him and I
said you know I really don't think this
is a good use of my time and I never
forget the look on his face and he
looked at me and he said what are you
saying
I said I don't think this practice of
law is good use of my time he said well
what are you gonna do I said well I'm
just gonna go back and pick up where I
left off and business to me Ann Arbor
and I'm gonna try and build a real
estate business
then he looked at me and he said you're
gonna do what and I explained to him
that that's when I was gonna do and I
thanked him very much for the
opportunity and he said well I've got a
suggestion for you I said why don't you
just stay here and the law firm will do
the legal work on your real estate and
we'll invest with you and help you get
started and I thought about that 170
that's a terrific opportunity and so I
said fine and the next day came back to
the office and I was no longer a lawyer
and I was chasing deals they at the time
he had a policy in this law firm where
they would give everybody 50% of any
business they brought in and the
methodology behind that was that we're
trying to in effect encourage young
lawyers to be a little entrepreneurial
and maybe they're getting the stage from
somebody in the family who died or the
contract but the whole idea of
quote/unquote hustling business and so
they in effect offered me the same
objective and of course I started
creating huge amounts of business and so
I don't know maybe four weeks later they
came to me and I said well we had this
deal where we gave you 50% but that was
really under the assumption that maybe
you bring in one deal and so you'd get
one positive experience but the volume
you're doing I mean we can't afford to
give you 15% so we're gonna make a 35 I
said okay so then three or four weeks
later they came back and they say well
you know we made this deal with you at
35 when we were assuming you were gonna
bring in this amount of business and now
you've brought in twice as much and we
got to cut it down to 25 I said okay so
we'll cut it down to 25 and so in effect
at the end of the first year I think
that this is 1966 and at the end of the
first year I think that my quote-unquote
job paid me $7,600 after I passed the
bar on a per annum basis
and I think I made $75,000 as a result
of my percentage of the business I
brought in well that was a huge number
and I was obviously thrilled about it
and then they gave me a bonus and the
bonus was $200 and I said I remember it
was the most depressing thing I what I
wanted was recognition what I wanted was
them to understand that I was really
pretty instead like virtue of paying me
$200 they were telling me that what I
was doing wasn't very valuable and I
remember I was so depressed I didn't
know what to do and I went to the gym
and I shot free throws for an hour or
two hours just to try and get this buzz
out of my head but then I realized that
I had a leave subsequent to that not too
long thereafter the end of the year I
was gone and set up my own shop so let's
go back to some of those early deals
because in many ways that's sort of
where you cut your teeth on your
principles that principles that have
sort of guided your career through some
of the largest deals in real estate
history can you recall sort of a
representative deal from those days what
was your sort of overarching principle
on real estate well I think that one of
the most significant things that
happened was that while I was in law
school I went home and I sat down with
my father and my father had been a very
successful businessman and had joined
other people in investing in quote
unquote commercial real estate
opportunities so I came to him and I
said tell me about your deals and he
kind of proudly looked at me so sure and
he started describing it to me the deals
he had invested in and when I listened
to him I realized there was a consistent
theme to what he was talking about and
basically he was investing in deals that
were in major American cities New York
Chicago Los Angeles San Francisco but
nowhere else and second of all he was
getting what he was very proud of was a
4% return and I had been doing deals in
me Ann Arbor where I was getting
16:20 25% and I just didn't understand
and then I realized how I came to the
conclusion that what he and his buddies
were doing or investing in what was
already existing proven commodities
which were the major cities and that in
effect if I were willing to invest
outside of those major cities I was in a
competitively better position whereas he
was investing in New York Chicago and
Los Angeles etc I ended up investing in
Ian Arbor in Madison Wisconsin and Tampa
and Jacksonville in Orlando and Reno
Nevada and Arlington Texas all of which
were small cities growth cities and ones
where there was no competition and it
dawned on me that when it was all said
and done the single most important
criteria as an investor was what was
your competition and to the extent that
you were able to operate in invest in
arenas where there was little or no
competition you got much better deals
and where there was more people a lot
more deals and a lot less attractive
returns as a result and so that's when I
kind of learned about or it didn't
really understand what I was learning at
the time but what I really concluded was
that competition was terrific
particularly for somebody else but for
me the real goal was to find situations
where I could operate in a competitive
environment that gave me the edge and
that became a principle of everything
that I did and so whereas the first
major deal I did was an apartment
building in Toledo Ohio and you got to
understand that part of the time not too
different from today
Toledo wasn't a very popular place and I
was keenly aware of that
but what I realized also was that
because Toledo was a car manufacturing
center and because it was referred to
often as the armpit of the nation and
in a very negative environment that also
meant that no insurance company that
made all the loans for real estate was
gonna underwrite a deal in Toledo when
the statistics the city was shrinking
etc but all I looked at was the fact
that I was able to buy one of the few
apartment buildings in town so I didn't
have any competition so that deal was
one of the most successful deals that I
had ever done simply because there was
no competition and therefore where
there's no competition
you can produce exceptional margins and
that was a great first lesson and how
did you price it are you pricing this
based at the time that is are you
thinking about this just on the basis of
cash yield or were you factoring in some
sort of equity improvement in this real
estate that assumes a much greater
knowledge level for me that was
conceivable at the time all I looked at
it was how much we're reinvesting what
was the cash on cash return the first
deal the cash on cash return was 19
percent this was in the same environment
where I'd seen my father was investing
money at four and my father had just
sold a number of interest in deals so he
in effect
I brought him this deal and he looked at
it scans and basically said yeah come on
this is [ __ ] but he called up a
friend of his who was a property manager
and said you know my son Sammy is
brought to steal and it's ridiculous is
19% but would you take a day and go look
at it so the guy went and looked at it
came back and said you know it's a
terrific deal and I've adjusted all the
numbers and became much more
conservative but it's still an 8% return
in an environment where 4% was the
standard so he recommended that we go
ahead with it and he put some of his own
money in it and so we did the deal
and sure enough it produced 19 percent
just like I said it was gonna but that
was the first deal your dad came in with
you yeah and how did is the second year
my father when I was in school I ended
up buying a square block
house-by-house and I didn't have the
money but I had enough to tie up the
properties and he eventually came and
put up money and helped me get that
first thing done but this was the first
quote-unquote investment deal and is
that something that did you pause for a
moment I guess and take some pride in
that in a way that was like wow Here I
am I'm now indirectly sort of helping my
family support itself as well or was
that just sort of below the radar of how
you thought about it couldn't even
imagine thinking that way all I thought
about was here was a transaction and
made sense I thought it was terrific
from a yield point of view it never
dawned on me that this wasn't what
everybody did by the way that's kind of
a theme in what I do in that when I did
was I never really understood that what
I was doing was so unique I just thought
I was kind of making it up as I went
along and I went from that deal to one
in Orlando and one in Tampa and one in
Reno and cetera et cetera and after the
first deal was the last time I ever had
any trouble raising money so that first
deal required two hundred eighty
thousand dollars of equity which in 1959
was or 1968 or whatever it was was a lot
of money but once I'd done that one
transaction people lined up to invest
with me probably they were enthralled by
the fact that how could a 25 year old be
actually doing this I never knew that
every other 25 year old didn't do it as
well never even crossed my mind I just
kind of did what I thought made sense
and you're sort of realizing this
principle though already right which is
being where everybody else is is sort of
not the place to be I mean you've
written about this a lot as we sort of
fast forward for a moment I want to go
back to this but even if we stand here
today now of course everybody looks at
Sam you've created an asset class that
we haven't even got to yet that we're
gonna talk about but you really come
back to very fundamental principles when
you speak about things you talk about
supply you talk about demand you talk
about competition as though those things
still apply where
as many people today sort of think that
come on that was econ 101 that mattered
when there was a huge sort of gap when I
took econ 101 at the University of
Michigan I walked into the first class
room and written on the blackboard was
supply and demand and I have to be
honest with you I'm not sure that there
was ever anything else in econ 101 that
I learned that was relevant and if you
understand and are focused on how supply
and demand affects pricing how it
affects decision making how it affects
risk
it's the governing principle of
everything but it's also simple what was
your philosophy around purchasing assets
that were already capable of deploying
yield versus developing assets well at
that time there were a lot of quote
unquote
income producing assets that were
available I've always been a great
believer that there's a lot of quote
unquote execution risk that has to be
fit into your thought process when
you're making a decision in that
particular time again keeping it very
simple if I could establish a definition
of cash flow and in effect I would
literally remember going to developers
and saying it's real simple
take the bottom line multiply by six and
that's what I'll pay now I didn't know
that that was a very high price I was
creating a price structure that was very
attractive to me
I just thought gee I wouldn't do this
unless I got a 16% return so 6 times
cash flow made perfect sense and that's
the way I thought about it that's the
way I thought about how do I raise money
in the same manner what was attractive
enough to get somebody to entrust their
money to me when did you start to
appreciate the operational side of risk
so in those early small deals like your
first deal in college where you're
basically buying homes on a block and
renting them back to students I assume
you're the one rolling up your sleeves
you're the one doing the heavy lifting
at some point as you start to scale this
enterprise you have to now trust other
people too
you operate this business how did you
make that transition and how did you
manage that risk again I think giving me
way too much credit I just don't think I
thought about it that way I mean I
thought about the fact that somebody had
to cut come on and I knew that if I grew
the size of the business it wouldn't be
me that I cut to Roman and not being
going cutting the lawn or cleaning the
hallways or whatever was certainly as
much an objective as making money so did
you ever go into deals where you were
the developer now and you were gonna
take that sort of construction risk as
well I did that in late 60s when I built
my first apartment project and it lets
you in Kentucky and what I also built
the project that ultimately led to my
relationship with the Pritzker's which
was this project in Lake Tahoe
in both cases they were development
projects and they were from the ground
up and in both cases and I was very
disappointed and how difficult it was
and I kept looking and saying this
doesn't make any sense you're taking all
this risk you're starting to build
something when you don't know what the
markets gonna be like when you finish it
maybe you're putting it up for rent or
you're putting up for sale it depends on
what the conditions are when you finish
you're subject to variances and costs I
mean there's no greater lesson of
inflation than designing a project and
finding out that it costs 20 percent
more than you thought it was going to
cost because the costs have gone up in
the mean time so all the variables in
the weather and all the things that
happen and contractors making mistakes
and when they made a mistake there was
nobody else to blame it on and the fact
that they made a mistake it was too bad
but I was the guy who had to live with
that mistake and then lived through it
so I kept looking at all the variables
and saying I don't understand why would
anybody be a builder when you're taking
on all these variables and the best
thing that happens is at the end you
produce the same thing that you got when
you bought an existing stream of cash
flow
you mentioned Jay Pritzker a moment ago
how did you meet him I had a friend of
mine who is
a National Broker of real estate and he
and I were friends and he called me one
morning and he said I was in Atlanta
yesterday with Jay and I said Jay who
and he's Jay Pritzker and I said oh yeah
I heard of them they're very wealthy
people in Chicago he said Jay is really
extraordinary and Jay is looking for
somebody to come work for him who is
under 30 a lawyer and a successful real
estate entrepreneur and I said to this
guy I said well if somebody actually met
those criteria why would they want to
work for Jay or frankly work for anybody
else and he says you being too glib this
is an extraordinary guy you really need
to meet him and so I said okay so he
called Jay and then the next morning I
went over to Jay's office and nine
o'clock we just hit it off and I sat at
his desk from 9 o'clock until 4:30 and
meanwhile he took calls him he made
deals and I listened then we talked
about everything back and forth and when
we got to lunch he sat me down and he
said this is an incredible opportunity
for you Sam you can come work for me and
do real estate deals and you got to keep
5% of everything you do and I looked at
him and I said gee that sounds like a
pretty great deal and he didn't laugh
but I said you just need to understand
that if I have all of the
characteristics that you really want
then you shouldn't be able to hire me
and welcome Utley up 4:30 that afternoon
and I said to him you know I said rather
than spend all this time where you keep
trying to convince me I should come to
work for you
why don't we just do a deal together and
so we did a deal together and that was
the first of maybe 10 or 15 deals that
we did over the years in various
different places and different kinds of
structures that led me to spend a lot of
time with him and find him to be one of
the most intriguing individuals and
frankly the smartest risk guy I ever met
what did you learn from him about risk
boy I'm not sure I know where to start
but I think it ends with the fact that
you had to be
realistic he had to be able to look at
it and say what could go wrong you know
if I learned any of the room I learned
that everything if it went too well you
could survive the only time you couldn't
survive is if it didn't go so well so
focusing on the upside was interesting
but not productive focusing on the
downside was what risk was all about and
to the extent that you could quantify
the downside to the extent that you
understood what the risk it was you were
taking your chances of survival were
much better
I think the key ingredient that is
focusing on what is the risk you're
taking I think a lot of people get in a
lot of trouble because they do a
transaction and they don't understand
what the risk they're assuming is when
they do the transaction and what he
taught me more than anything else was
look at the deal and figure out where is
the vulnerability where is the
assumption you've made that has to be
right in order for the deal to work and
we were working on a deal in then in
1969 and it was very complex and I put
together a very complex presentation and
sat down with him and took me 25 minutes
to explain how we were gonna do this and
do that do this and do that and at the
end he looked at me and he said well
step 7
is the only step that's really relevant
that's where the risk is if you can
satisfy yourself that step 7 in this
case it was a multi-use complex and the
risk really was could you release the
office space if you could leased the
office space everything else worked so
all the other things that I did to
mitigate this to mitigate all irrelevant
only real issue was could you or could
you not rent the office space if you
could the deal was kind of work if you
couldn't all the other stuff didn't
matter and the ability to zero in on
what it is that represents the
decision-making risk that's really
where it all comes down and that's
really what I learned from him and Sam
is it's safe to say that those lessons
apply across all asset classes I mean is
there an asset class where that logic
doesn't stand front and center for you
if you're someone like me who's thinking
about where to invest 401k dollars do
you still think about it through that
lens I don't know how you can think
about in any other way I mean if you're
investing 401k dollars you're basically
trying to provide for your retirement or
for your future so then the question
becomes okay what stands between you and
achieving the objective and if you can
understand what it is then you can
quantify the risk can I rent the office
space if I can rent the office space if
I can bet on Raleigh North Carolina
being a growth area because of the
Research Triangle that's the assumption
that's what makes you decide to invest
in Raleigh or somewhere else there's
always some epiphany point that is what
motivates you to make the decision and
that's the ultimate judgment you make
this is why I'm doing this
why is a critical ingredient and why
usually connects to the word risk where
did you meet Bob Bob and I pledged the
same fraternity at the University of
Michigan in 1959 we were both part of a
21 guy pledge class I didn't know him
very well
we then both worked on the campus-wide
thing called soft shell and we got to
know each other a little better but
basically didn't really know each other
at all until we were friends and like
all of my fraternity brothers but that
wasn't really a big fraternity guy and
then when I was a senior and I had
started this real estate business I was
in the house one night for dinner and he
said you know I heard you were renting
apartments and kind of running a little
student housing project and I said yeah
and he said that's really intriguing if
you ever need anybody else to join you
you should call me
and literally a couple months later we
got our third building so there were two
of us together and we now needed a third
guy so we talked about him we offered
Bob the opportunity to join us and he
did and eventually and bob was an
engineer and very very organized
character so he in effect started
turning what was literally hardly a
business it was two guys trying to get a
free apartment and helped us turn into a
business and then when I graduated from
law school I was confronted with this
incredible decision of what was I gonna
do at that point I think I made a
quarter of a million dollars my senior
year in law school it's just an enormous
amount money and I was a big deal in a
small pond and and the question was
should I stay in Arbor obviously it done
very well there and I knew everybody and
I went back and forth about it and I
finally said you know I have to find out
how good I can be I have to find out
what I can do
how far can i push and test my limits
and so I decided that I was going to
sell everything in Ian Arbor and moved
to Chicago and see if I could build a
career eventually it came time to figure
out who I was gonna sell the business to
and Bob became the obvious person
because he was going to stay there
I basically sold him the business and
the last thing I said to him was I said
when you get tired of screwing around
and you want to come play with the big
boys call me we laughed and I laughed
and then I moved to Chicago and we
continued kind of a very touch based
relationship but not much and then about
three years later he called me and he
said Sam do you remember the last thing
you said to me and I said yes and he
says well I'm ready and I said without
hesitation I said come on and so he
moved to Chicago and I was very
sensitive to the fact that I didn't want
him if he was going to be my partner
didn't want him to ever work for me
and so I said instead of paying you a
salary I'll give you an opportunity
to own a piece of the deal and as time
goes on we'll increase that to the point
where we eventually become partners
50/50 partners and literally that's what
happened we started out at 85 15 and
then we were 70/30 and then we were 6040
and then we were 50/50 and it all became
an example of transference of risk
because he in effect began taking on the
risks that I was taking and we built the
business together
I remember hearing somebody once talk
about great partnerships I wish I could
remember who said this and the gist of
what they said was excellent
partnerships are when you have they just
use the example of two people obviously
partnerships can be more than two people
but they said when you have two people
who have complementary skill sets but
shared values did that describe you and
Bob yeah I've never heard that phrase
but I think that's exactly right in
other words our skill sets were very
different I mean he was really an
engineer I mean you literally if the
books didn't balance the numbers didn't
try it he would just stop until they
tried out I would believe well they're
close enough you know and next and I
would be willing to go talk to anybody
and chase down anything and and he was a
homebody but we had a unique
relationship and we could finish each
other's sentences we understood each
other and later on and kind of
understood also that a very important
part of our partnership was that we
didn't have much of a social
relationships so we didn't have the
classic partner of the wife who says how
come they got this and we got that we
basically had independent social lives
in both had wives both had children but
we focused our time together on our
enterprise and once a year we had dinner
the four of us and we had a wonderful
time but we never really tried to
connect the personal day-to-day
relationship with a personal
relationship to building a business so
we spent 99% of our time focusing on
bill
our business relationship and very
little time and we ended up with
completely unrelated social
relationships were you one of the first
people that Bob told when he was sick
yes I was but to be honest with you I
didn't understand it do you remember
what he said to you yeah I mean he come
down with a relatively aggressive form
of cancer that he was gonna get
chemotherapy and I just assumed that he
would suffer a little bit he'd be fine
and we'd go on when as this was in
September of 87 that he told me that we
went on and he had surgery and he had
various issues and suffered a lot but
then came back and I just never assumed
that anything was other than just gonna
be painful process but there was never a
terminal end to it and then in February
of 1990 he came down to the office on a
Saturday and he hadn't been to the
office for a month and he said I came
down today cuz I wanted to talk to you
and I said okay he says I want you to
know that I'm gonna die and I looked at
it and said you're gonna die that wasn't
on the list of options that I thought
was possible he said no no he said you
don't understand I've been trying to
tell you for a couple of years now that
this is very serious and very rampant
and that not too many people survive us
and he says it was obvious to me that
you just didn't accept that as a
possibility and you needed to know that
we're at the end here now and I've got
to prepare for it I'll never forget that
morning as long as I live because it was
so shocking to me because it just never
even thought that dying was an option
that that there could be a terminal
event here I mean you know when I got a
cold he got sick and we got really I
didn't really connect it but it was from
that point forward that we started to
prepare and he eventually died in June
of 1990
did his loss change anything in you with
respect to your horizon your risk your
desire to do the work or were you able
to compartmentalize that and sort of
move forward I mean how did you think
about losing a partner who was your
equal at that point I think that as I
think back on it I think that all I
could think about was our legacy and I
think that I was more motivated rather
than less motivated and then I wanted to
do more because as far as I was
concerned everything that I did
represented me and represented him and
later on when I endowed the real estate
center at Wharton I undoubted under
Samuels L Robert Lori and when we did
the entrepreneurial center of Michigan I
did it under Samuels on Robert Lori
because everything I thought I was doing
I always thought I was doing for us and
that I thought what I did and how I did
it reflect it as much who I was as I
wanted the world to remember who he was
his wife has really carried on quite a
legacy I mean I actually heard of Bob
even before I'd heard of you many many
years ago through his wife's legacy of
their philanthropy yes well first of all
the two of them before Bob died spend a
lot of time talking about philanthropy
and they both decided it's very chic
today to talk about The Giving Pledge
but this was 1990 nobody heard of The
Giving Pledge but these two people said
you know we have a fortune that we've
made and we have to give it away and we
want to give it all away and we don't
want to burden our children with any
significant inherits or the burdens that
come with it
and so in effect before he died they
kind of had a pact as to what they were
gonna do and she happened to be a nurse
so particularly focused on medical and
eventually Lori Hospital and a lot of
other things that she did that were all
involved in medical and created a
wonderful legacy for him
shift gears for a moment and talk about
an asset class that many people take for
granted today called REITs which I'll
have you explained to folks but what I
think is most interesting is the role
that you've played personally through
your firm and actually creating
something that we now really take for
granted so maybe spend a second
explaining what a REIT is and then let's
kind of hear about basically the
creation of what's now a more than
trillion dollar asset class it all began
in 1958 when President Eisenhower signed
something called the cigar bill and it
was some kind of legislation had to do
with ski cars and I don't know what it
was but somebody had added a provision
that created the quote real estate
investment trust and the idea was that
they wanted to create a vehicle that
effectively created an opportunity for
small investors to own pieces of large
real estate projects and the Reap
concept basically said where as a
corporation is subject to double
taxation because REITs
or real estate was illiquid they
eliminated one of those two steps so
that in effect the REIT law allowed the
creation of a vehicle that didn't pay
corporate tax but only pay tax on the
distribution and the requirement was
that in order to qualify for a REIT you
had to distribute most of the income so
that was created in 1958 and they were I
don't know how many there were but they
were probably 10 or 15 they were created
over the next give or take 25 years the
industry never grew very much by the
time 1991 came around the entire
industry was only seven billion dollars
and the reason was that the private real
estate market was so much more
attractive that the REIT world
up until that point only attracted
people that came from insurance
companies are non entrepreneurial
scenarios and effectively it was just
kind of a byproduct of the real estate
industry but all the action was on the
private side in other words people
weren't buying pieces of REITs people
were actually doing private investments
in real estate directly I mean that's
when I did know it's you know we built a
major real estate company we had huge
office apartments retail but ordinary
people like me could not have
participated in that time would have
been very difficult so the idea was that
it create these REITs and then the
classic description was the little old
lady from Pasadena who wanted to own a
piece of New York office building but
effectively because it was so
unattractive compared to the private
real estate side it attracted very very
few significant players it retracted
very limited amount of capital it was
kind of a backwater of the real estate
business and then in 1989 we ended up
with a very serious oversupply of real
estate and that led to a couple
insurance companies went broke the
Savings and Loan industry went broke and
little by little all of the sources of
capital that had funded the private side
disappeared so people like me were
sitting there saying you know where is
the capital they're going to come from
for the real estate industry in the
future somewhere along the line the
thought process became well it's going
to be real estate investment trusts and
in effect we're gonna have to access the
public markets in order for the real
estate industry to continue going
forward and so we began studying in and
actually working with Merrill Lynch on
the first of the quote modern area area
REITs I became very involved in the
processing because I recognized that
this was the solution and that
ultimately this if done right would
ultimately fulfill the ultimate dream
which was quote-unquote liquid real
estate
because ultimately real estate was
illiquid and that was a big problem so
if you could create liquid real estate
then the scope of what was available was
dramatically more available than ever
before and in 1993 in October the
National Association of real estate
investment trusts which was really a
another backwater organization whose
sole objective was to protect the reach
law as written in 1958 with no
understanding of the bigger scale
questions and liquid real estate and
what this was all about in 1992 at the
National Association of real estate
investors conference I think they had 20
people between 1992 and 1993 as more and
more people became more and more
knowledgeable when we had our conference
in October of 1993 in New Orleans we had
1500 people they'd never seen that many
people involved in anything to do with
real estate and the national association
of real estate investment trusts asked
me to give the keynote speech I remember
working on those bullet points for the
speech as I was flying into New Orleans
and I basically got up there and I said
to them I said guys I said we have a
horrible track record as a real estate
industry dealing with the public because
up until then the only reason that there
was any kind of a public real estate
trust or a real estate anything was
because there were no other options and
there was you know so if you wanted to
dump some properties you created a real
estate investment trust and you took the
worst of your properties and sold it to
the public and this public were the fish
you know the old poker story of if
you're sitting there and you don't know
who the fish at the poker table is it's
you well that's how they did it and then
it was not driven on what were the
basics of real estate or cash flow it
was basically driven on commissions so
it was very short-sighted because all
the action was on the private side and I
basically said I remember in that speech
I said I was driving around used in the
1984 and I saw a bumper sticker
and the bumper sticker said please God
give us one more oil boom I promise we
won't screw it up this time that's where
the real estate industry was in 1993 and
we had an extraordinary opportunity to
take this and make it into something
really significant but we had to be in
effect custodians of the public's trust
as opposed to them that took advantage
of the public's trust
now speaking of you started this story
by talking about the savings and loan
crisis in the early 90s you wrote a
letter in the late 80s and I don't think
you necessarily predicted the S&L crisis
but you certainly foreshadowed the
circumstances that led to it yeah I
wrote an article for NY I used real
estate center this is what 88 this is 88
i sat around trying to figure out the
title for the article and I ended up
coming in conclusion that the right
title for the article was from Cassandra
with love Cassandra was this lady in
Troy who was cursed by the gods by
making true predictions that nobody
would believe and I then sat down and
wrote out an article that basically
predicted what was going to happen to
the real estate industry and what the
future was true to form of Cassandra
nobody believed me everybody said Oh cm
the pessimist again he's trying to
discourage other people so he can have
more of the market I mean just all kinds
of non-recognition an unwillingness to
accept what to me was simple logic but
it reflected what has been a kind of a
hallmark of my career and that is my
ability to sit down and think through
where is tomorrow and how can I identify
where tomorrow is going and how can I
position myself to take advantage of
that and that article led me to lead the
whole conversion of the real estate
industry to the real estate investment
trust industry and create liquidity in
that speech in October of 1993 I
predicted that we would be 250 billion
dollars in 10 years and well on our way
to a trillion and everybody thought I
was
truly insane what is that number today
just shy of a trillion dollars what is
it that you saw in 88 that you knew was
going to create a real problem in the
next couple of years because again it's
easy I think now to say by the way I'm
gonna give you another question I'm
gonna ask you in a moment just so I
don't forget it as much as you I want to
talk about the differences between 91
and 2008 because you in many ways saw
both of these coming though they were
very different types of crises so I want
to come back to that but it's easy to
look back at 2008 and say well of course
there was gonna be a credit crunch
because of X Y & Z and it's easy to look
back at 91 and draw the same conclusions
it's not that easy to say it before it
happens and it's hard to go back and
sort of remember what you saw at the
time without the knowledge of hindsight
yeah I guess all I can remember about
that period was that this was the 80s
when the Japanese invaded the US market
the Japanese came here and made the
ultimate classic mistakes and all kinds
of investors have made coming to the
United States and that is what works in
my home market obviously this works
somewhere else in a different market
the Japanese flooded the market with
capital occupancy Revels across the
country in every form of real estate
were down supply was way out of whack
and it wasn't very hard to predict that
this was the end of the world in terms
of real estate and I remember vividly
when I started raising money for the
first real estate Opportunity Fund in
1989 I was confronted with the challenge
where I walked in and sat down with an
insurance company or a pension fund and
I said the end of the world is coming
here's the oversupply here's the dis
here's to that and they looked at me and
some waited what are you talking about
we just heard from our ma I our
appraiser that our portfolio has gone up
in value
I said that's BS that's not ever
happened look at the numbers look at
what the numbers are telling you and
look at where tomorrow's numbers are I
remember giving a speech at that time
and talking about the fact that the
missing element was we didn't
have enough tenants for all the
occupancy that we were creating so you
were raising a fund at that time for
distressed assets basically you knew
that the shoes gonna fall I don't have
lots of dry powder for when something
happened but nobody had ever raised a
fun before not for a distressed property
so you're talking about an asset class
that people can't fathom at that point
in 1989 80 percent of the institutions
that I pitched to didn't have real
estate as an asset class let me make
sure I understand what you're saying
you're saying in 30 years ago 30 years
ago
80% of pensions and endowments didn't
have real estate as it was of glass
that's correct they owned stocks and
they own bonds and that was it and there
were a couple of really far-out
investors who had some real estate but
there was a very famous study by Epogen
heidi bo t sen that in 1992 reached the
startling conclusion that real estate
was a separate asset class but prior to
that so here's this guy coming in and
worse than that he didn't even wear a
suit and tie and he's pitching us and
the fact that the end of the world was
coming and get ready and be prepared and
be part of a fund and that first fund
was unbelievably difficult to raise and
then the rest of them were very simple
so what was different in oh wait because
I think for many people listening to
this I don't remember the savings and
loan crisis because I just wasn't really
old enough but I remember learning about
it when I became involved in credit risk
more than a decade later or about a
decade later and so it became a
historical lesson and it had some pieces
that were similar 208 but some pieces
that were different you lived through
both of these therefore you're in a much
better place I think to explain where
they were similar and where they were
different and why the second one
ultimately was much bigger Wow but
that's not true sorry I should say why
it had less contained well the 208
crisis was the first recession since
World War two where real estate was not
in oversupply it
the beginning that's really not the
truth of the matter is the oversupply
was in single-family houses but that's a
different class than commercial real
estate but commercial real estate
although it wasn't great in 207 although
I sold equity officer 207 but by the
time 208 came it was softening but it
wasn't an oversupply every other
recession 7380 189 all of them were real
estate recessions triggered by
oversupply so that made 208 very
different than all the rest of them it
also meant that this also occurred at a
time when interest rates were going down
so whereas in the past when there were
over supplies there was an enormous
incentive on the part of the lenders to
get rid of it at any cost
in 208 the cost of carry was going down
therefore the motivation to get rid of
it was much less and the lenders were
willing to take less hits therefore the
opportunities as a distressed buyer in
Oh 1809 were nowhere near as attractive
as they had been in the other cycles
yeah actually remember you writing
something on that and that was a big aha
moment for me because I didn't have the
historical context you laid out but I'd
saw a way up close and remember thinking
that's a great point if you have a
declining interest rate environment
heading into a crash it's a totally
different animal but remember all of the
previous crashes were precipitated by
rising interest rates so 73 I mean
interest rates went as ty and 73 is 12%
which was just unbelievable at the time
so the cost to carry to a lender in
terms of taking back a property was very
high so they bit the bullet we also up
until 1990 the real estate business had
a very different accounting treatment if
in 1975
from 73 to 75 or 77 I probably blocked
more real-estate than anybody in the
United States I've all of it was bought
a dollar down in a hope certificate
because I'd go to the insurance company
and at that time the definition of
taking a hit was a scenario that was
quote unquote not recoverable within
five years so if you could make a case
that it was recoverable within five
years you didn't have to take it right
off by the time we got to 1990 the game
had changed and you in effect had to
take a write-off based on the discounted
cash flow and so in effect coming up
with a deal for a dollar down and a hope
certificate and giving him a long day to
note you didn't have to mark the note to
market created a very different
environment so in 1973 the name of the
game was make the transaction happen by
1990 the name of the game was you had to
be able to discount it out and so
therefore in 1973 I didn't need a lot of
cash I raised the fund because I
realized the only way I was to be able
to take advantage of this enormous
market opportunity was by basically
paying cash and buying stuff at 20 and
30 and 40 cents on the dollar is it safe
to say Sam that commercial real estate
occupancy or glut or supply demand
however you want to think about it is
kind of a canary in the coal mine for
the US economy historically that has
been the case mostly because that
oversupply is usually a function of too
much capital availability and not enough
discipline so in effect although it may
end up creating over supplies in real
estate it inevitably
creates problems in other forms of
finance as well so in 1989 when we had
that massive oversupply of real estate
we also had the beginning of the LBOs
and then the lbo started they were very
conservatively financed by the time five
or six years ago and by they were very
aggressively financed and can you
explain to people briefly what a
leveraged buyout is sure a leveraged
buyout and in effect is taking a company
and whereas the normal company would
have let's say 30% leverage you buy it
by in effect creating 70 or 75% leverage
and you make a whole series of quote
media improvements that improve the cash
flow and quote create the opportunity to
make a lot of money going forward make a
lot of money because so much of the
value is in debt at that moment in time
and in effect the equity is very small
so if you make some significant
improvements the impact on a very small
amount of equity is pretty gargantuan
mm-hmm now as we sit here today and
record this and there's no one listening
to this who hasn't been following the
story of we work but you were one of the
first people to talk about we work
through the lens of marginal supply and
in many ways there are a few people that
can comment on that type of a business
model more than you what is it about we
work that years ago had you scratching
your head saying I don't understand this
business unfortunately not understanding
it was not one of my problems I think I
understood it pretty well what you
didn't understand why it could be viewed
as so valuable well I mean my first
exposure to the we work model which is
basically leasing an office floor for 15
years and then breaking it up and then
leasing it to small users at higher
rates the first example of that was okay
I mean Paul fijian in the late 50s in
the late 50s and early 60s no new office
building existed without a floor to
lease to fijian and then supply became
much more prevalent and he went broke
and then somebody else did it again and
they went broke and eventually even
today the largest co-working company in
the world called Regis they went broke
why because if you're the marginal
supplier when things are good everybody
uses you and when things start to soften
you're the first one to feel the impact
so the idea that we work with
some kind of technology company I didn't
understand that unless maybe they came
up with a special way to underwrite beer
or something but it was basically a
giant promotional effort you know it's
just the Enron of real estate you know
it's funny hearing you describe it in
marginal terms makes so much more sense
for someone like me who doesn't have a
great knowledge of economics but knows
enough when you look at the marginal
cost curve of oil you realize the reason
the tar sands get hammered first in 2008
exactly the same is once the marginal
cost became below the cost of crude
you're hosed well just think about it
what was weworks competition it was a
plug at Starbucks in other words the guy
came in he any occupied a desk from you
but if things got tough he went back to
Starbucks and plugged his computer into
the wall and he was in the co-working
space first of all that insight to me is
it's a great example of how after the
fact it's obvious but before the fact
you think how was that not more obvious
but come on how could it not be obvious
I mean where did these guys come from
they came from Starbucks it's just such
a great way to think about I mean the
question that I keep asking people about
we work was just tell me the cash flows
that we were generating what do they
come from do they come from profits in
other businesses or do they come from
venture capital which in effect doesn't
have the discipline of profitability and
the answer was obvious and it still is
today and by the way when it's all said
and done any company that doesn't have a
barrier to entry is vulnerable in any
business just look at how many
competitors we work as spawned now most
of them ovens spawned because we work
sold this technology concept but the
reality is that they're creating new we
works all the time just calling them
different things there's something else
that I know in the tech space we've
talked about before which is governance
and this is something that you've said
so many amazing things on governance
everything from it one under the
spectrum which is you wouldn't buy a
business that you couldn't
run on one level you sort of have to be
able to run a business that you're going
to yeah I mean that's why although we
have been agnostic and we've been in 25
different or 30 or 50 different
businesses but the standard has always
been if I can't run it then I don't want
to own it and so we don't do rocket
engines
we don't do biotech because if the
proverbial hit the fan
I could always step in and there have
been numerous examples over the years
where I've had to step in and take over
and temporarily make something work but
if I can't do that then that's above my
pay grade I'm disciplined enough not to
get involved and things that I couldn't
run if I had to another principal of
yours
is sort of everybody has to have skin in
the game well I mean to me that's not a
principal that's just basic logic I mean
if I'm depending on you to perform and
you aren't at risk I'm a fool so every
single thing I've ever done including
when I first started in business from
the first day everybody who was in a
decision-making position in my firm's
always had a piece of the action and
that piece of the action required an
investment now it might be a very small
investment but relative to their net
worth it was meaningful and they had
skin in the game speaking of your firm
saying you you've you know spoken to
several people who have worked for you
and I know people in your circle it's a
little bit unusual in the the extent of
loyalty that has followed you you tend
to collect people they don't really go
anywhere yeah I don't know whether
collect is that I never thought of that
in terms of collection but I think it's
true but they don't leave I don't leave
we have a long history of even if you
went to my world today you'd be shocked
at how many people have been there for
20 and 30 years and obviously I take
great pride in the fact that they have
had the confidence level to stay with me
all these years and in many cases in
different roles I mean you know it's um
that's also always been part of it it
was I'm I'm really focused on the
individual and his or her capabilities
if I have trust in somebody and I have
confidence to somebody I'm just as
comfortable having him do business a or
business B because I think in the end
the success or failure is really a
function of how good a businessman you
are how good are you were making
judgments and that's what separates the
men from the boys so creating this
long-term loyalty and connectivity is
very important how do you do it I don't
know it just kind of happened to me but
I when I look around in my own world I
can't help but say that one of the key
things that has separated and
distinguished me from other people is
that I have always been accessible in
other words I make a joke of the fact
that I've had the same office for
30-some odd years and only four years
ago did I discover there was a door on
the office because I'd never closed the
door so that means that I was available
to everybody and by virtue of being able
to be accessible to everybody I'm in
effect lowering the overall risk because
there's no excuse if Sam's available the
same manner I've never had much of a
hierarchical structure never even
thought of it that way everybody wears
the same thing to the work every day and
there's no secrets and you know one of
my favorite words is the enemy's without
my words we did a little drawing of a
bunch of wagon trains circled and the
point being that the enemy is on the
outside not inside supposedly Abe
Lincoln created a team of rivals
well maybe running a government you need
a team of rivals I don't know but you
run a business you don't need a team of
rivals you need a team of partners who
are rivals to the outside and that's
always been a critical part of the way
we think in the way we operate you told
a story once about a woman working for
you who came to you and said she'd had a
change of heart and she wanted to go to
Divinity School how did you handle that
well I mean the answer is in the end
nothing is more important and in effect
facilitating people to test their limits
reach their goals and she sat down with
me and said I'm at a stage in my life
where I really need
change how I'm thinking and although I
didn't necessarily envy her or want to
go to Divinity School myself I said well
if that's what you want to do then how
can we arrange your work schedule so you
can go to vanity school get a degree and
still stay relevant in the business
world and that's what we did what does
she do today still works for me and she
doesn't do any Holy Roller stuff but in
effect that experience is very relevant
to what she does and her almaas scenario
given ease and other things which is
wonderful we have a mutual friend which
is how we met and one day I was in his
office this is probably five years ago
and I saw something in his office and I
was like that's an incredible piece of
artwork and he said oh so Christmas
present from Sam Zell and I would learn
later when you and I met that there's
more to that story
so tell me a little bit about how you
think about these gifts well I think you
got to go back to 1976 I've been in
business for give or take I don't know
eight years and I'd started getting you
know chocolates and grapefruits and all
kinds of Christmas things pens pencils
and I felt motivated and felt that I had
to somehow rather respond to always
people sending me this stuff but the
idea of me sending out a calendar with
my name on it or a pen or a pencil I
just
it's just crazier than making that that
wasn't who I was and so I decided that
what I was gonna do was I was gonna send
out to people some momento of where my
head was in that particular year and so
the first year I sent out just a simple
lucite block with a Sam azzam on it
which was we suffer from knowing the
numbers every year I kept coming up with
something different that reflected where
my head was at or where I thought we
were going or what I thought was
happening and then when you do something
for a very long period of time it tends
to get out of hand and so by 1994 the
idea was well let's do a music box and
so we did a little automaton with a
music box and it happened to be VG's
song but basically
talking about where we were and you know
where the real estate industry was and
then we kept going and we did that for
another 20 years
how much time goes into preparing that
well the answer is a lot we ended up
doing a lot of these very complicated
automatons and we ended up getting a
group in California that did the models
for Star Wars movie to start doing these
year-end gifts for me probably took
about six months the good news was we
produced really exciting products the
bad news was that I was basically making
a prediction where my head was at six
months before it was delivered history
turns out that I was pretty good at that
I mean probably the most significant
example of that was December 31st 1999 I
sent out a piece that was basically
calling an end to the dot-com boom and
it was basically the emperor has no
clothes and the song was Paul Simon's 50
ways to make a billion I basically made
fun of the idea that people had just
thought that it was just so easy and
let's just in at all any idea for that
year's gift had come when somebody said
to me you know you must really be pissed
off you spent all those years becoming a
billionaire and these people became a
billionaire overnight and I said when it
turns to cash call me you're kind of a
lifelong student earlier you alluded to
the fact that a big part of how you
mitigate risk is know as much as is
possible about your world now when you
were investing in dime bag stores on the
side of annarbor blocks the world was a
lot smaller than it is today
so how do you stay abreast of your
environment in the environment you
invest in today what do you do to learn
I read and I read and I read and I read
I'm never without something that I'm
reading I read five newspapers a day I
read three magazines a week I listen I'm
trying to observe I'm trying to figure
out and when I think about it I think
about the fact that
I have some kind of a unique capability
to sift through volumes of information
and only remember the parts that are
relevant I mean I read maybe wondering
to have books every two weeks and most
of them are escapist novels and when I
read them it's grisham it's about dachi
it's whatever it is it's just I'm very
involved I love reading him and the day
after I finish and I can't remember
anything about him I don't remember who
the protagonist was I don't remember
anything but if there was a description
of Berlin I remember the description of
Berlin because that in effect has
potential relevance going forward and so
somehow or other I'm able to get rid of
the what I'd call the non relevant
information great stories was very
entertaining while it happened but it's
not relevant to tomorrow and some other
am I able to hang on to and use that
kind of unique information so one of the
stories that's applicable is as I was on
a motorcycle trip in Chile and last day
it rained like crazy and we were we cut
the trip short by a day and we started
coming home early and I realized that we
were gonna get home at 3 o'clock in the
morning and that didn't make a lot of
sense and so we're trying to figure out
what Jesus could we stop someplace on
the way from Chile to Chicago and where
could we stop and then I remembered that
I'd read this protagonist escapist book
where the final scene was a shootout on
a golf course on an island in the
Caribbean and that this golf course was
part of a resort that had an
international airport inside the resort
and we ended up coming up in the name of
the airport and I named a resort and we
ended up landing there spending the
night and then coming back to Chicago at
4 o'clock the next afternoon but that
was really typical somehow or other the
only thing about the story that I could
remember
was this a unique scenario of
International Airport inside of a resort
I don't remember anything else about the
book
I don't Romanian other than the shootout
at the end but the only thing that was
relevant in the book to me in the future
was the airport in the resort everything
else was superfluous but it's that kind
of segmentation and absorption that I
think contributes to the decision-making
that I'm constantly making I'm
constantly adding and increasing my
knowledge of everything in every
direction I can I mean a number of years
ago I went to Lula and doctora
why would I go to Hulu on bat or while
on bat or happens to be the capital of
Mongolia and I had read someplace that
they had opened Gucci store and another
high-end retail store in Ulaanbaatar and
I said why would they do that and it
turned out that the country was in a
giant resource boom and so I said we
gotta go look at it and see what's there
that's kind of the way I attack and look
at all kinds of information
it can't be an entrepreneur unless
you're really curious you gotta see the
problems you got to see the solutions
and you can't see them from afar you got
to see them upfront that's why and I end
up traveling a thousand hours a year on
my plane the typical CEO of a fortune
100 company travels 250 hours a year but
I gotta see everything and when I'm
making risk decisions and I'm making
decisions on partners I want to see them
in their home territory almost anybody
will come see me if I invite them but
that doesn't do me anything it's also
particularly relevant that if you go see
them you can decide when to leave you
mentioned obviously travel you have been
to some crazy places you've been to
places that most people don't think of
his vacation destinies like Iraq and
Syria yes I don't take vacations and
that effect that word is kind of foreign
to me I've never been one to sit on a
beach I don't know how to do that I just
want to see stuff and you know one of
the great stories that my wife and I
talk about is that we went to Syria
right
for Syria came apart and we went to
Damascus and we went up into the various
parts of Syria and we had one day that
we just didn't have enough time and so
we said well we'll go to a leper next
time
and in between course Aleppo was
destroyed so that only motivates me more
to constantly see stuff and one of my
great stories was I saw this video of
the biggest copper mine in the world and
here in Jawa it was run by a company
called freeport-mcmoran out of New
Orleans and I ended up at a conference
sitting next to the CEO and I said I
just read about this incredible mine and
I want to go see it and he said tell me
and I'll set it up for you so we flew
into the jungle where there was an
airport literally built into the jungle
just to serve the mine and went up to
the mine and saw stuff that I never
forgot
so it's curiosity it can't be an
entrepreneur you can't be a risk-taker
unless you're also just ape about
knowledge and you just got to keep
absorbing and in separating out that
which is relevant and that which isn't
it's very easy to get overcome by too
much information and therefore you can't
make decisions so you've got to be able
to sort it out
I mean you alluded to that earlier when
you talked about your very first
Christmas gift which had a quote about
what was the exact quote something about
least suffer from knowing the numbers
yeah how do you draw that line I'm a
person Sam who will always err on the
side of analysis paralysis maybe it's
because I was an engineer I don't know
and obviously knowing none of the
numbers is counterproductive
how have you navigated that balance or
maybe asked another way how would you
teach somebody or help somebody find
their own way
well the origins of that sentence we
suffer from knowing the numbers really
reflects the fact that there have been
numerous times in my career when
everybody else was doing stuff and I
wanted to do it too except I knew too
much it was too knowledgeable and so I
didn't know as much then I could make
the same mistakes they were
but by virtue of knowing the numbers it
became the disciplinarian factor that
kept me from making a mistake and
becoming part of conventional wisdom
instead of an independent thinking so
you actually are praising the knowledge
there and not criticizing I'm not
criticizing at all I'm saying that it's
a burden I mean it'd be so much easier
if I didn't know so much then I could
just say hey everybody's buying my Fang
stocks you know jump on the bandwagon
but that's just not the way I think and
I've spent my whole life trying to
separate what other people think is cool
and what I know is something different
so you're in your 70s if I'm doing my
math right and you're not even close I
mean you'll never retire I never asked
you this question in other contexts but
I know the answer like I get exactly
what does retire mean to you retire
would mean stopping something that is
retired from what yeah exactly I mean I
haven't worked since the fourth day that
I was in that Laufer
or as my dad used to tell me make your
vocation your vacation you'll never work
a day in your life and that's exactly
what I've done I mean I've spent my
whole life I loved everything I've done
I love getting up in the morning I never
was found myself getting up in the
morning and saying oh my god I gotta go
do this again and I've tried very hard
to focus my life on never doing anything
I don't want to do and never being
anyplace I don't want to be with all the
lessons that stand behind you lots of
people think the US economy has been too
frothy for too long and lots of people
myself included are wondering oh my gosh
should I be sitting in all of these
equities at this moment should my 401k
be distributed this way versus that way
I will certainly won't ask you those
types of granular questions but on a
more macro level how bullish are you on
the US economy at this point in time and
I guess just for context we're having
this discussion in October of 2019 so
what's your view you've been through
every cycle and you also have the luxury
of seeing cycles both in and out of this
country because of the nature of your
work what do you think about the world
we live in today
well when
as said and done you have to think from
the perspective of what I call pure
logic for 25 years and people ask me
about interest rates for 25 years the
United States the risk free rate of
return was 5.6 percent if the risk-free
rate today was 5.6 percent the country
would be broke as with the rest of the
world so you start with the assumption
that the world we live in creates a set
of limitations I think one of those
limitations today is that nobody can
afford for interest rates to go up so
therefore I think that in with the
amount of debt being created that's even
more the case today
so I think that number one I think we're
probably I don't think we're in a
bullish environment despite the fact
that stock market today is at an
all-time high I don't think it's the
same kind of an all-time high as it has
been in other quote frothy periods I
think we've pretty much come to the
conclusion that growth is limited and I
think growth is limited but I think
growth is going to continue to be
positive I'm very sensitive to the
question which I get all the time about
what inning our in but I also think that
people aren't focused on what I think is
even more important question when did
the game start so in the stock market it
was January or February of oh nine but
if you were in the real estate business
the real estate business was really
terrible
in January of 10 in January of 11 in
January of 12 and only started beginning
to get better in 13 and 14
so what anything are we in when did it
start and I think the same thing is true
of a lot of other things so I guess what
I would tell you is I think that the
environment is benign not aggressive not
pessimistic I think that our whole
system is based on or built on
and we are in a period of substandard
growth and substandard growth I think is
also recessionary to in effect defers
recessions so I think it's very likely
that we will continue to bounce along
till the beginning of 21 and maybe even
for longer because in effect that
central banks don't have the tools with
which to defend themselves therefore
they have to keep the process benign and
as you see here we are in what's
supposed to be the eighth of the ninth
inning and instead of the Fed raising
rates they're lowering rates yeah that's
the weird thing isn't it it's sort of
like having a fire department that's low
on water wow that's one way to look at
it but I think another way to look at it
is it it's having a fire department who
figures that the best way to sell to
mitigate the risk is to wet everything
down before the fire begins yeah yeah a
slow drip with sprinklers yes well I
like the way you're thinking about that
and I like your optimism in terms of the
u.s. is positioned globally Sam look I
mean in the 80s as you described earlier
everybody thought that Japan was coming
to eat the lunch of the United States
today obviously that sentiment has been
replaced by China do you see the
relationship between the US and China is
much more complicated and much more
intervene or do you see them as
independent economic behemoths well I
guess you gotta start by the fact that I
think that China has been taken
advantage of the United States for 20
years I think when China was admitted
into the WTO there was an assumption
that by virtue of them being admitted
into the WTO that they were gonna behave
differently the reality is they've
behaved as every mercantilist since the
beginning of time and we have not had
the what I'll call independence or
clearness with thought to understand
what was going on and only now are we
frankly out of necessity creating the
kind of environment that challenges
China and in effect says to them you
can't can
to take advantage of us and if you do
we're gonna change the terms of the game
and of course that's a very political
question which I don't think either of
us want to dive into do you believe that
we are tethered to each other in some
way from a sort of supply and demand
standpoint in other words do you believe
that the fate of one country rests
somewhat would the other independent of
behavior change well I think that
there's little doubt that all of the
countries of the world are much more
connected today than they ever have been
obviously the two biggest by definition
are much more connected I don't think
that we can ignore China's existence nor
do I think China can ignore our
existence and one way or another we have
to find a middle ground where China can
continue to prosper and grow
but not in the mercantilist ik
fortunately like identifying five
industries they're gonna pour capital
into to take over a high and stuff like
that we can't afford to let that happen
Sam what advice would you give to
someone like me so like you I'm
first-generation and when I look at my
kids they are growing up in an
environment that has more to offer more
opportunity more privilege more comfort
than the environment I grew up in I have
to imagine the same is true for your
kids how do you think about instilling
in our kids the lessons and virtues that
first-generation kids had instilled into
them without much thought on the part of
their parents because they were the
defaults I guess no matter what you say
I think it comes down to can you inspire
your children can you encourage your
children to excel my message to my
children has always been go for
greatness
I never fantasized of anybody that my
children working for me if it turned out
that one of my children had the talents
necessary that'd be great but what I
really communicated to them over and
over and over again is
find what makes you happy find the
challenge and then excel at it be the
best you can and who you are and with
the talents that God has given you
that's the message that I've given to my
children over and over and over again
yes I've been very successful and yes
they're gonna have less challenge
financially than I did but financial
challenge is not the ultimate answer the
ultimate answer is can you maximize what
skills or genes or understandings you
have and make a difference that's what
we're on this earth for and that's what
our responsibility is and I as a parent
and responsible to inculcate my children
with that and hopefully what I've done
financially and otherwise gives them the
freedom to truly excel at whatever turns
them on last question Sam outside of
your business world what problem are you
most interested in I know that your wife
who have had the privilege of meeting
Helen is very involved philanthropically
as you think about your priorities over
the next 20-30 years
let us pray where do you see the ability
to apply your problem-solving your
resources to problems that go beyond
your day-to-day problems within business
which is you're constantly a problem
solver there well I think maybe the best
way to describe it to you is that I've
been very focused on freedom of speech
I'm very very concerned about America is
truly unique America is like no other
country in the world I've been the
beneficiary of that and the challenge
that I have in the thing that I worry
about most is can we keep America
capable of providing unique
opportunities for people to test their
limits in Excel and freedom of speech is
one of the most important things I think
and I've been very concerned about
what's going on in the college campuses
what's going on in business where
politically correct
is the standard that in fact I think
challenges the freedom that has made
this country great and so that's
probably the single biggest issue that
concerns me more than anything else do
you think the pendulum is just going
through a cycle and that we're just
seeing a very extreme end of it with
respect to that particular issue I hope
that's the case
but I'm not sure that is the case and
I'm not sure that the perpetuation of
standards in universities or or in the
workplace it's not changing our society
in a way that ultimately is going to be
deleterious to the future into the
opportunity for our children and our
grandchildren well Sam I know that for
you to sit down for this long is a big
ask so I am really grateful for this
chance I feel like in some ways we
barely scratched the surface of all of
the stories that are out there and all
the Sam isms we didn't even get to 20 we
made a scratch the surface of five or
six of them but I want to thank you so
much for your time today
and I've enjoyed this discussion as much
as any I've had with you well it's my
pleasure and it's very fulfilling to
think that people will listen to this
conversation and will reach their own
conclusions and find what parts of it
resonate with them and if I've created
that kind of an opportunity and the time
spent is very very very change
thank you Sam
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday and that provides a little
morsel of fun for the weekend and five
bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek comm all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it this
episode is brought to you by brave the
next generation web browser
I love brave and if you haven't heard
about it here is the skinny brave was
built by a team of privacy focused
performance oriented pioneers of the web
and I do mean pioneers brave was
co-founded by Brendan Eich the I CH and
Brian Bondi Brendan was previously the
co-founder of Mozilla Firefox and the
creator of JavaScript brave now has more
than 10 million monthly active users and
I'm one of them why why would I use
brave because brave gives you unmatched
speed security and privacy when I say
unmatched and the difference is hard to
believe and here's why
every time you download a web page when
you go to any web page you are not just
downloading the text and images you are
also downloading yep junk this includes
trackers and scripts that run in the
background slowing your downloads and
wasting your time by an average of 5
seconds per page while also draining
your battery faster and costing you
extra in data charges there is a way to
have the best experience web can offer
and that is by using brave brave is up
to six times faster than other browsers
and it's truly incredible how much
faster everything is I have used brave
for instance to get on airplane Wi-Fi
when other browsers crash I have used it
to watch youtube videos when it's just
suspended in loading forever on other
browsers it's not subtle little there's
a huge difference other browsers act
like a vacuum cleaner or your data so
this is on the security privacy side you
were being profiled and tracked across
the web so what you might ask well data
collected about you can be used to
manipulate both your decisions and
countrywide decisions like elections and
if you want more on that listen to my
episode with Tristan Harris brave is a
way to protect yourself and remove the
surveillance economy brave also includes
options which I use quite often such as
private window with tor for those
seeking advanced privacy and safety this
browser feels intuitive it's super easy
to use you can import your bookmarks
with one click and all your favorite
Chrome extensions are also available
with Braille and it doesn't have to be
either/or you can use multiple browsers
for different things
now listeners of this show the chimp
airshow can easily upgrade their browser
for free and all you have to do is go to
brave comm forward slash Tim that's
brave comm board / Tim I use brave all
the time and I strongly suggest that you
at least test it out so for the brave
comm forward slash Tim and give it a
shot
this episode is brought to you by fresh
books longtime listeners of this podcast
know that I've been talking about fresh
books for years
it's the all-in-one invoicing in
payments and accounting solution that
came about because I was doing a
revision of the 4-hour work week for
2009 looking at new software solutions
that could help people help my readers
and fresh books came up over and over
and over
many entrepreneurs as well as
contractors and freelancers I work with
all the time use fresh books more and
more every day why is that wealth most
people especially entrepreneurs business
builders hate wasting time doing things
in efficiently painful invoicing with
different cobble together solutions
including Word or Excel can fall into
that category you want to avoid that
pain what can you do give fresh books a
try fresh books is accounting software
that makes invoicing another bookkeeping
tasks so easy you can save up to 200
hours per year that's a lot of hours
here's how it makes fun of your business
easier you can automate bank
reconciliation in just a few clicks you
can give your accountant access to the
information they need to do your taxes
this is a huge one I've realized how
important this is and how much it makes
life easier when you get this done with
many things you can't accept credit
cards ACH payments right on invoices to
get paid two times faster and of course
you can create customized and send
branded and professional with the
invoices in about 30 seconds with plans
starting at just 15 dollars per month
fresh books is designed to grow with
your business and right now fresh books
is offering with my listeners that's you
guys a free 30-day trial with no credit
card required simply go to fresh books
comm slash Tim and enter Tim Ferriss in
the how did you hear about us section
that's fair after 2 hours of nasus of
course check it out
go to first books calm / Tim and start
your free 30-day trial today first books
calm / tip
you
[Applause]
you